SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Hi, everyone.
We're going to go ahead
and get started.
People are walking
in from lunch.
I'm Shiva Rajaraman, and I lead
the product team for our
platforms, effectively creation
as well as developers
and our APIs.
And I'm joined here by Ibrahim,
who's working as a
developer programs engineer,
and Andy, who heads up
engineering.
And we have a special guest
who'll join us in a bit.
So the purpose of this session
is to do something we've
actually never done before,
which is to really lay out
some of the areas of development
around our
platform that we're most excited
about and give you
some of those examples.
And in addition to that, walk
through some actual executions
that are really stretching our
platform in new directions and
which we'd like to
see more of.
So with that, though, let me
first start off with a very
important announcement for
today, which is that we're
actually doing two things
when it comes to live
streaming on YouTube.
One is that our live API is
wild, and we'd love to see
people start to use it.
The second piece of it is that
we're actually opening up live
self-service on YouTube to a
much larger group of channels.
So anyone who is basically a
channel in good standing and
has over 1,000 subscribers on
YouTube, effective as of 12:45
today, can start to apply to
actually live stream through
the YouTube Platform.
In the past, that was a very
restricted audience.
We're really ironing things out,
but we're ready to scale
it out to everyone.
So with that, though, there's no
better way to showcase what
we can do than a demo, which
Ibrahim will walk through.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Hi, everyone.
Today I will actually show a
small demo from one of our
partners, Elgato's Game
Capture device.
So I will play a game called
"APO Snow." And I will show it
live on YouTube.
So let's get it started.
So I have my game here.
And actually, the first thing
I will do is I will
authorize the game.
So it will use my credentials
and create
the event on my behalf.
Allow access.
And now I can actually change
the game title.
"Watch me Play at IO."
I can set the maximum
resolution I want.
I'll see it public for now.
And it will be like a gaming.
And I'll start streaming.
Right now, it actually-- or
device starts capturing the
audio and video.
It encodes it.
And it starts streaming
to YouTube.
While it's actually preparing
this stream, let me check in
my own YouTube account.
And I see it's actually
preparing it.
I see it here.
"Watch me Play at IO." In less
than a minute, we will
actually see it live.
And let me turn it
to my game here.
You'll see it's on my tablet,
and I will start playing.
And you'll see in a second
that it will be live.
And while I'm playing, actually,
Google's still
streaming it over there.
Well, it's kind of harder
to play it online.
Thought it was easier when I
was snowboarding myself.
But we will see.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: You did
really good last night.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yes.
We can do few tricks, I guess.
Well, it was not actually like
showing my real stuff here,
but let's go back to
the streaming.
And it should be almost there.
And let's see.
Yeah, we are just like
few seconds away.
And our stream is here.
In only like, I guess, 5
or 10 seconds, we will
start seeing it live.
And let me actually talk about
the structure I'm using today.
Actually, I have my tablet.
I'm playing the game and using
their device, actually, which
they already used the
Live Streaming API.
It actually starts capturing the
whole audio and video and
compresses it.
And it sends it to
my laptop here.
And I start streaming from the
laptop using live API.
Oh.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: We are live.
That was just a few seconds
ago I played it.
I will keep playing.
See where [INAUDIBLE] is now?
Thanks, everyone.
That was me, and I'm just
handing back to Shiva.
[APPLAUSE]
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Nice.
Thanks for that.
So thank you.
That was great.
It's always hard to pull these
technical things off during
one of these presentations.
And it's amazing that we
have 15 cords, and
this actually worked.
So congrats.
So what I'm going to do is walk
through, again, something
we're doing for the first time,
which is how we look at
the developer ecosystem and
some areas that we're
particularly excited about.
But first, I just wanted to
walk through some of our
principles.
And so one of the key things
is we do want to make clear
and emphasize that we do see
ourselves as a platform.
And as a platform, we're really
excited about people
who create good applications
that effectively extend
YouTube and take us into
verticals or domains that we,
as a horizontal platform,
may not be good at.
And some of these principles
are really, really key.
So one of those is with the
launch of the Analytics API
which is live, effectively,
as well this week.
We are very excited about this
idea saying, hey, YouTube is
one of the greatest
focus groups
that's ever been created.
So how can we get that data
out to people who can then
take it to verticals and take
it to different applications
and really extend it
and make it useful?
So one of these principles is
get that data out and let
people use it.
We don't believe in just
hoarding data and keeping it
isolated to the platform.
The next one is very important,
which is this idea
of embracing developers that
really extend YouTube.
For the most part, what we try
to discourage more and more is
just building a bunch of YouTube
clones that mimic
everything we do with
a different brand.
And we'd prefer to have people
who take us into the world of
food, the world of gaming, for
example, and take us into
different areas which might
actually make YouTube both
better, or something that can
sustain on their own and
develop a unique audience, or at
least take our audience and
go deeper with it.
We'd like to see more of that
happening in the ecosystem.
For the most part, it's quite
phenomenal what is out there,
but building a clone app
typically is hard to sustain
both from a business model
perspective and an audience
perspective.
So go a little deeper.
It usually pays off.
The next one, which is also
very important, is that we
have millions of partners
who monetize on
YouTube, the platform.
So one of the big principles
we have is that as content
flows from YouTube into
developed apps in the wild,
preserve those creator
interests too.
Usually that's about
monetization, but sometimes
it's also about how can you
start to help those creators
and do something special
for them?
And I'll walk through some
examples of that.
And then finally, we'd like an
experience where if you come
to YouTube as a viewer, and
you personalize that
experience, when you go into
another app, take advantage of
that personalization.
And while we're not talking
about it today, someone like
Flipboard's really a good
example of that.
You can set up your YouTube
channel in Flipboard.
You can auth to YouTube.
And then you can get your
personalized subscriptions on
YouTube right within
Flipboard.
And so those types of
solutions are great.
And rather than recurating
things for users, which
sometimes make sense, sometimes
it makes sense to
build on the profile that
someone's set up on YouTube
and extend it further.
So to start with, I thought one
great example would be a
media company, actually,
Tastemade, that is extending
our platform in all of
these dimensions.
And we're very excited about
them, because they're doing
this in many different ways that
really opens up YouTube
to a whole new audience.
And one of the things with
Tastemade, even their media
company-- it's probably the
first media company that's
ever existed that has
more engineers
than business people.
So it's a great example that
they actually believe in our
APIs, believe in the platform,
but are doing a ton of things
to actually extend it.
And the best way to showcase
them is to actually jump into
a video of an example that
they've created using our
platform and using our audience,
but using a lot of
tools that we'll go into.
And it's right after lunch, so I
don't mind showing you food.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[HINDI SONG PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: So this video
is two people who've
effectively created
a cooking show by
traveling around the world.
And as you can see, it's
very polished.
The food really shines.
Some nice titles and editing
that goes into it.
Looks a little more tasty than
what we served you today.
So go ahead and pause.
OK, jump to-- yeah.
And what's going on behind the
scenes is that Tastemade, as a
network, is effectively saying,
hey, what if anyone in
the world, one person, two
people, could effectively
become the next Gordon Ramsay?
What are the tools they need to
get access to editing and
production expertise
in any region?
How can they translate that to
different places and create
good content like this?
Second piece that they're
really doing is
really going very deep.
And they're going deep into food
and travel and trying to
really own that domain by
creating hundreds, if not
thousands, of channels in every
different country in the
globe, but also creating a tool
set so that people can
actually join a network and
cross-promote and find their
audience, without having
to do that one by one.
You can almost think of them
as like this platform for
content apps in the food
and travel space.
Then finally, they do some
things that we as YouTube are
not so good at, which is
effectively building a
community where if you're an
aspiring person trying to
create a cooking show, you can
find peers who are really good
at some of the types of skills
that you need to actually
build a cooking show, which
means you might want to find
someone who's really good with
a slow-mo camera, because
there's nothing better than
showing the spices bounce in
the pan when you kick off
one of these shows.
Or you might want to find
someone who's really good, an
expert of lighting and different
food angles.
That's something that's going to
be very hard to find in the
wild unless someone builds a
community around it, which is
what they've done.
So one of the things they've
done is effectively created
these community pages around
every creator on YouTube.
And they use our Analytics API,
as well as our Data APIs,
to get the information there.
And then they extend it by
effectively saying, hey, this
person's a chef.
This person's actually
a great food editor.
This person's a great
food copywriter.
And you can find these people
in almost Kickstarter-style.
These projects can now be
funded, which are effectively
video projects, around new
channels on YouTube.
They also do some great stuff
around the Analytics API.
They've been in the beta
program, and they've been
pulling things like subscribers
or views.
One of the things that they'd
love to see happen is that for
any creator, you have a
currency, a reputation, that
gets built up around YouTube.
And so as people are looking
around for people to
collaborate with, like a
Ukrainian chef who's
effectively looking for a local
community to create a
good show, what they can do is
look up those people and then
see the videos they've produced,
and see how many
subscribers, those channels,
and how much watch time and
views those videos generated.
So it's this reputation layer,
specific, again, to food and
travel, that they're adding
on top of our platform.
It's really exciting, and
they're making the UIs work
really well for anyone who
might be a casual user.
And next, what they've done is
said, particularly with food
and stuff, it makes sense to
have a magazine-style mobile
app for this.
They've taken all the Tastemade
content on YouTube,
using the Player APIs, have
put that into an app.
And in turn, they do things
that make sense for food.
In this case, when you're
watching one of these videos,
you can actually see a full
downloadable recipe for those
videos as well, which makes
perfect sense and is not
something right now
that's available
on the YouTube platform.
So it's a good example of an
app, tons of videos, that they
extended to make sense
for their vertical.
OK, with that, I'd like to zoom
out a little bit and talk
more about the developer
ecosystem and some areas we're
particularly excited about.
And then Andy's going to come
up and walk us through some
showcase examples.
So this is the first time we're
actually doing this and
actually consciously thinking
about what are some of the
segments we're excited about.
So the labels are still rough,
but I'll try to explain them.
In the top left is creation.
You saw things like live
streaming and capture.
It's very exciting for us.
We'll walk you through some
examples, including a guest
star on the discovery
and context side.
These are the true viewer
consumption-oriented apps.
So folks like BuzzFeed who might
be all about news and
really interesting moments.
They are now integrating video
fluidly so it's keeping
engagement in their apps high.
Then we have some folks on
the enterprise side.
So enterprise is very hot right
now, partially because
there's lot of money
flowing to it.
But also, when we look to the
future, we think about tens,
if not hundreds, of $100 million
run-rate businesses
being born on our platform.
And in order to do that, we need
platform companies out
there, who are building
on our APIs to
service those verticals.
So we'll talk through a few
examples of that, but
Tastemade is one good example,
which is how can a media
company, in food, actually
survive and
also thrive on YouTube?
And they're doing a bunch of
things to extend that.
And we'll continue that.
And then finally, analytics
and promotion.
With the Analytics API out
there, as well as things like
posting through the APIs, we're
excited about folks who
are taking our data and
verticalizing it, whether it
be for music, more
horizontally, or
cross-platform.
We'll walk through some
examples there.
So we're going to start
with creation for
our showcase examples.
And I'm going to invite someone
to come up on stage--
Jussi?--
to do a demo of someone
doing something cool.
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Hi, guys.
How are you doing today?
Everybody excited by the current
Chromebook Pixel?
At least I am.
So my name is Jussi Laakkonen.
I'm the founder and
CEO of Applifier.
And in Applifier,
we're building a
service called Everyplay.
And Everyplay's about getting
those elusive but awesome game
moments out from mobile games
and into YouTube, Facebook,
Twitter, and through those
things to your friends and
family to enjoy together.
The reason why we're doing this
is the word-of-mouth is
the number one way how people
decide to download a new
mobile game.
We did a survey in March, and
we found across 1,800 people
that word-of-mouth was
neck-and-neck to App Store.
And this is corroborated by
studies by [? e-dar ?],
Forrester, and Nielsen.
The best way to discover a game
is when a friend pulls
out an Android phone and tells
you, you got to play this!
Check it out.
That moment of social proof
needs, I can see what this
game is about, is really,
truly awesome.
But the problem with this is
there's only so many times I
can go out and have a latte
with my friends.
So instead of that, could we
take this offline moment and
take it online?
And that's what Everyplay's
about.
In our survey, we also asked
mobile players on how do they
feel about sharing.
And we were very pleased to
discover that 20% say that
sharing video replays
from mobile games
is extremely important.
Not somewhat important,
not quite important,
but extremely important.
Now that's one piece.
So we know there's a
set of people who
want to share content.
But what about video?
Is this a great way to capture
the dynamic nature of gaming?
And we found out that,
yes, it is.
In the same survey, we also
asked them, what have you done
after watching game-related
video?
And nearly 50% said that they
had immediately decided to
download the game.
And also another roughly 20%
said they decided not to.
So video drives decision
making.
And it drives, also, referral
to friends.
Hey, you got to check this out,
this crazy replay that I
saw from a game.
Now with that, the challenge
is how do we get an awesome
replay out of "Bad Piggies"
and into YouTube?
And that's where Everyplay
comes in.
So we looked at Elgato, which
is a fantastic piece of
hardware, but I think it's even
better if you don't need
any additional software or
any additional hardware.
So now we're going to go into
a really hairy live demo.
So let's see how
this plays out.
So I'm going to switch
over to this one.
So here we have a ordinary
box-standard iPad mini,
running the latest build of
Rovio's "Bad Piggies."
And let's turn on the sound,
so we can hear
what's going on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: So when I'm
thinking about Replay-Capture,
I'm capturing something that I
do not know whether it's going
to be cool or bad.
It's going to happen.
And I'm just going to be playing
a game, not thinking
about really replays.
And I'm just going to take a
level and start playing.
And so here, this is a level
I too start already, but I
thought it was such a fantastic
contraption of this
pig taking a ride
with four-wheel
vehicles, so let's go.
So I'm going to send the piggie
on his fly, and I'm
going to tap on the Capture.
And we're now capturing a
gameplay as it happens on the
background while
the user plays.
No additional hardware, no
additional software.
It's baked straight
into the game.
And this is actually live on
the App Store right now.
So you can get "Bad Piggies"
from Rovio with Everyplay.
And now what we can do, we
can check out the replay.
So this is what we
just recorded.
And it's now on the device.
And obviously, the next step
is to get it out from the
device, so we want
to share it.
So we open up Everyplay and
the sharing interface.
So Everyplay is an embedded
application within "Bad
Piggies." So we're still
in the same game.
We're going to give this a
title, "Bad piggies." And
obviously, we want to
share it to YouTube.
We can share it to Facebook
and Twitter.
I'm going to do that too.
And I'm going to tap on Share.
There we go.
So now it starts uploading.
And I'm posting to Facebook.
So I'm going to send
it to Facebook.
I'm going to send
it to Twitter.
And obviously, I want to also
send it out to YouTube, which
happens on the background.
So we use the YouTube Upload
API, so that we upload first
to our own servers.
And from our own servers,
we upload it to YouTube.
So while this being transcoded
by our servers and YouTube's
servers, let's look quickly
around Everyplay.
So Everyplay's really kind of a
vertically-oriented solution
for mobile gaming.
We're building a model name
that you can follow
interesting game creators,
replays, and discover games
that you haven't maybe
seen before.
So this is me on Everyplay.
This is my home feed,
people I follow.
So we have a social
follower model.
So why don't we go and
check out a replay
from the Popular tab?
So there's a whole lot of stuff
from "Bad Piggies." Why
don't we check out this
crazy contraption?
This has about 100,000 views
in a couple of days.
So this guy built a rocket
out of a bad piggie.
So it's going on a flight.
It looks pretty good.
Oh, there we go.
So Jarek's just favorited my
tweet, so I should have turned
off notifications
for this demo.
And obviously, if I haven't yet
played "Bad Piggies," I
can just tap on the Install
Now button.
And it opens up the app sheet
from the App Store.
And now I can install
the application.
So it's kind of an embedded
discovery mechanism, also, for
the creators.
One cool thing we also do, which
we don't yet have on
"Bad Piggies," but I'm going to
show you very quickly, is
that we have the opportunity to
have the players actually
provide commentary from their
games that they're playing.
So well, I would show you if
this loads, but it doesn't
seem to be loading.
So let's try again.
Somebody once said that doing
live demos is like
playing with fire.
You're going to get burned.
So let's do this very quickly
if it loads-- yes.
And I'm going to
go to my Home.
And so I have a very special
message for all of you here at
I/O which I pre-recorded,
actually, at the YouTube
headquarters, where
I was yesterday.
And didn't play.
Let's try again.
The wireless is a little
bit flunky here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: Hey, everyone
at I/O. This is "Shadowgun," a
Unity 4 game that we're using to
demonstrate the performance
of a game running Everyplay.
And not only that, we are
also demonstrating this
shot, the face cam.
So that's me talking and lets
players annotate and comment
their game play.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JUSSI LAAKKONEN: So by now,
I'm pretty sure we have
YouTube ready with the upload
that we've done previously.
So I'm logged into YouTube.
I'm going to go into
my uploads.
And there are a couple of
"Bad Piggies" replays.
It seems that the latest one
didn't yet make it here.
Because it's a server-server
transition.
And there's a couple
of encoding passes.
So we're going to look
at an older version
that I did just yesterday.
But trust me, it does work.
But we cannot quite control how
long it takes to YouTube
to encode a video and
put it online.
I'm sure there's like
a fast track switch
I could pull, Shiva?
So there.
So Everyplay is an integrated
SDK that goes inside the game,
automatically records the
gameplay, and lets the player
share with their friends and
family on YouTube and other
social networks.
So as a summary--
and so we're going to
go back to this.
As a summary, our roadmap is
to use Data API to provide
discovery, to aggregate these
videos on YouTube.
And we definitely are planning
also to help people to bring
more gaming content into
Everyplay by allowing them to
embed YouTube videos.
We're really excited about
the launch of Live.
We support live broadcasting
in the SDK.
So we're definitely going
to be integrating that.
And my visuals also have
Annotation API, so you
actually add annotation
to videos and portrait
orientation.
There's so many games on
portrait orientation.
If you're interested in
discovering a little bit more
about what we found on our
survey of 1,800 mobile gamers,
the link is here.
You can find a presentation
on that.
And you can grab me out doors.
We have a food truck at the
corner Ford and Howard, if you
want to come out for
a cup of coffee and
more demos of Everyplay.
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY BERKHEIMER:
Thanks, Jussi.
Now I wanted to go through
a few other examples of
applications that showcase the
full set of APIs we have and
help set the stage for many of
the follow-on talks that we
have going on throughout
Google I/O
both today and tomorrow.
And after that, we'll leave the
floor for your questions.
First app I wanted to talk about
quickly is an app called
Woowa Brothers from Korea.
Woowa Brothers is a great
example of a mobile-focused
food review app.
One of the things that we
really like about Woowa
Brothers is as you go through,
you select your food, you eat
your food, you rate the
places you've been to.
As part of the rating process,
you can also take a video of
the food you've just eaten,
really help provide a rich
example of what this restaurant
is about, and
upload it directly to YouTube,
and then watch it
directly in your feed.
We think this is a great example
of both our Upload
APIs as well as our Android
Player API.
And it helps both the Woowa
Brothers bring a great
immersive experience within
their application.
It also gives them a platform
for distributing these videos
globally through YouTube, which
both draws attention to
their application as
well as to the
restaurants featured therein.
After you've had a good bit
of dinner, it's time
to play a few games.
And of course, one great example
we have of integrated
capture into gameplay is "FIFA
2013." I know our developer
programs engineer Jarek is
very fond of this game,
especially when he's reliving
the glory moments of his
hometown, Wisla Krakow.
So directly within the game, you
can capture your greatest
goal scoring events, share them
with your friends and
family, and get the best
bragging rights.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Five
views, whoo-hoo.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDY BERKHEIMER: And of course,
earlier, I wanted to
actually quickly hold up the
game capture HD, which we
demonstrated earlier
with Ibrahim.
So what the game capture HD
actually allows you to do is
take the HDMI output from any
device and live broadcast it
to YouTube through the Live
Broadcast APIs that we've
announced today.
On the consumption side, we also
have a number of examples
of great vertical integrations
of YouTube content into
consumption applications.
A lot of folks are familiar with
BuzzFeed, and BuzzFeed's
goal is to surface the latest
and greatest of the web, no
matter what type of
media it may be.
And so a lot of the latest and
greatest of the web can be
found on YouTube.
And so it makes sense for
BuzzFeed to have a very, very
smooth Android Player API
integration, so that within
BuzzFeed, you can find and
consume whatever media people
may be talking about.
And you can see here the
transition where directly
within the BuzzFeed app you're
able to go through to and
watch full-screen
YouTube video.
Interesante is a great startup
down in Argentina which is
building a way for users to
collect and share content of
interest to them across
all types of media.
And we think they're a really
innovative example of using
our Topics API to power
some of their
recommendations engine.
So they're able to use the
videos that you're interested
in to recommend other types of
content that may not even be
video that's also of
interest to you.
And vice versa--
they can use their knowledge
about your interests in
imagery and text media
to recommend
YouTube content as well.
[GUITAR MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY BERKHEIMER: I lastly
wanted to demonstrate
Soundslice, which shows off the
integration of the Player
API into a music and guitar
learning application, so that
as you're learning guitar,
you're able to play along with
your favorite YouTube stars,
whether that be the actual
stars or just a cover band.
And with that, I'd like to hand
it off to Shiva, who will
talk through a few other
examples in our ecosystem.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Cool.
We're going to shift back to the
back office and start with
analytics and promotion and
talk about some ways that
people are extending
our Analytics API
for particular domains.
So one of the exciting things
that's happening right now for
us is that we have a lot of
content networks and new media
companies that are launching
channels on YouTube.
And one of the key value
propositions they have for
their networks is really
to understand how to
cross-promote and also give
feedback from the overall
network to someone creating
something cool, so that they
have more ideas about what
they should actually be
creating that make sense
for their audience.
So a great example of
this is Tubular.
And what Tubular is doing, in
this case with AwesomenessTV
and network, is say, hey, for
any one of your channels out
there, you can come into our
dashboard and get a sense of
who your audience is.
And not only for that audience,
you can start to get
a sense of who in that audience
is influential.
But also what other things
are they also watching?
So if you think about that from
a network's perspective,
it's really simple.
It's, hey, this is great.
It's an awesome channel.
I seem to have built
a great audience.
Who should I collaborate with?
On the other side of it, what
we'd like to do is start to
keep extending this in terms
of thinking about analytics
integrating with Topics API.
What else are they watching?
And that gives you ideas about
what to create and who to
partner with.
So it's a great example of
someone who's taken,
effectively, a basic firehose
of data that we've serviced,
blends it together and
makes it work and
starts to extend it.
And very importantly, they also
take a look at analytics
from YouTube and combine that
with Facebook and Twitter and
other sources, so we
can create a great
cross-platform picture.
We love to see these
things out there.
And they're becoming very
successful, because this type
of knowledge is, for the most
part, missing from most
content creators.
Now, take the same theme and
take it deep into a vertical.
This one's Next Big Sound.
And what Next Big Sound does is
not just for a horizontal
platform across multiple
different types of creators,
but goes deep into music.
And they create a slightly
different UI.
And their UI is more focused on
what's trending in terms of
songs and artists across
various platforms.
And they really bring
that to life.
So you can see here how you
have YouTube video views,
you've got Instagram likes,
and you've got basically a
trend meter associated
with them.
The goal is that anyone can look
at a particular artist,
in this case Bruno Mars, and
get a sense of a complete
picture across platform
about what's going
on with that artist.
And they've made this UI very
friendly so that you can
imagine even the artist
manager or the artists
themselves being able to pop
into this UI and understand it
and hopefully get some
actionable insight
immediately.
So these are great examples of
things where you just take
data and you start to bring it
to life and visualize it, that
you can do very different
things
for different audiences.
And we're seeing these things
start to sprinkle and appear
on the ecosystem, but there's
so much to do here.
We know there's a big theme
of big data and
that type of thing.
But YouTube's a great example as
probably one of the biggest
data sources on the planet
that still has
yet to be mined fully.
And while our APIs are fairly
new, this is the right time to
start using them, because
we need that feedback.
What can you actually
do with it?
What's missing from it?
And we have a lot of different
sessions today and tomorrow
that are focused on
using that API.
So if you have a chance,
come check them out.
I'm going to jump
ahead of this.
The next one is getting into
the enterprise side.
We talked about Tastemade
already.
I wanted to show you another
one called ZEFR, which is
focused on the rights
management business.
And this is very--
if you'd seen our CMS, you'll
say, wow, this is a huge
improvement.
But I think one of the key
things is that when you look
at someone like ZEFR, what
they're doing is effectively
saying, hey, we manage content
for a lot of media
companies out there.
And we want to make it easy
for them to understand who
their fans are, as expressed by
actually uploading YouTube
content, but also what's
the ones that are most
important to act on?
Where are my revenue
opportunities?
So what they have is a team of
people who come into this
dashboard every day.
And what they do is build based
on our Content ID APIs
and our Analytics APIs to put
together a very good picture.
And the picture is, here
is content I can claim.
And I can make a decision about
whether to use that to
block that content, to monetize
that content, or even
further promote that content.
And they've made a very friendly
UI which effectively
creates a smart queue on
top of all this data.
So as a studio, I can look at
this and say, what's hot,
what's trending, and what's
revenue-opportunity, and act
on it immediately.
So these are things, too, where,
as enterprise gets more
consumer-friendly, we're excited
to see people actually
building very robust businesses
on the back ends of
something that back in the day
was really just thought of as
a way to just block content
on YouTube.
Now it's actually a huge
business opportunity for these
people, and increasingly,
an opportunity to
connect with your fans.
And with that, I'm going to turn
it back to Andy for the
recipe book behind this.
ANDY BERKHEIMER: I just wanted
to finish off by summarizing a
little bit about all the
different components that go
into building these applications
that YouTube
provides and to lay out the
landscape of what you can dive
into to learn more about at
Google I/O this week.
A lot of these applications
highlighted a number of our
latest APIs--
our Live Broadcasting API, our
Topics API, our Android Player
API, and our Analytics APIs.
And we have sessions and
code labs around many
of those this week.
Also, we're talking a lot about
some of the things that
go on behind the scenes
at YouTube.
This is something we haven't
done at I/O before.
This is something we're just
trying out this year, which is
discussing not only code labs
around the APIs themselves,
but also sharing knowledge from
our own engineering team
around many of the development
challenges and problems that
come up in working with video,
both to help you develop
better applications as well as
to give you a sense of some of
the heavy lifting and
infrastructure that goes on
behind the scenes supporting
these APIs.
We have a number of talks going
into details about how
we look at problems like
adaptive streaming, how we
look at incorporating video
encoding and decoding
capabilities into applications,
as well as some
of the user design challenges
and business challenges around
building these applications
around these APIs.
And if you remember nothing
else, just wanted to summarize
the talk for you.
A lot of what we're talking
about here today is ways that
we extend YouTube, not
just recreate it.
How do we create a larger
pie for both our
creators and our viewers?
And we've seen a lot of people
have success here by diving
deep into a vertical, diving
deep into a region, diving
deep into the specialized areas
where a broad horizontal
platform like YouTube will
never go on its own.
We really want to empower
creators.
YouTube started off as, and
still exists today as,
Broadcast Yourself.
And it turns out that there's
still a lot of challenges and
friction points in the ecosystem
and just in the
tooling to create and produce
a video that we see needs to
be met there.
And lastly, a lot of the APIs
we're going to be talking
about this week are very new.
Some of them have just
launched this week.
The rest have all launched
within the
last couple of months.
While we think that they're in
pretty good shape, we by no
means think that
they're final.
And we're looking here this week
to get your feedback on
ways that we can improve them.
So I just wanted to say
thank you, and leave
the floor for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY BERKHEIMER: And if you have
questions, please go up
to one of the mics.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
Phillip from ZEFR.
First, I got to say, we got to
get you a better screen shot.
That's just embarrassing.
So you talked a lot
about the APIs.
And our business utilizes
them quite a bit.
And what we keep running
into problems with
is the query limits--
the API quota limitations.
There seems to be one group
that's in charge of the
partner, one group that's in
charge of the Analytics API,
and another group that's in
charge of the GData one.
And as soon as we seem to make
headway with one, then the
other one, we sort of
lose touch with.
So as our business grows, it
seems like the incremental
adjustments to those API limits
really sort of hold us
back from actually being
able to move quicker.
So I'm just curious, what can
we do to actually get
something set up to be more
reasonable and help you guys
help us, and vice versa, so
that we don't have to keep
pestering you guys every week,
every month, to say, hey,
look, we've hit it again,
now let's go?
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Yeah.
It's a great question.
I think one of the things
we're doing is trying to
reorganize in some ways so that
we have single points of
contact for key partners,
particularly as they reach a
certain scale.
And so that working through key
points of contacts, you
can actually work through and
start to say, here's my plan
over the next two quarters.
Here are the milestones
I expect to hit.
And instead of hitting them and
then reacting, which is
kind of our status quo right
now, instead coming up with a
plan over the next year that
says that this is probably
going to be our demand.
We can keep a check on it but
effectively forecasting that
out and supporting
you accordingly.
This is something we've just
started reorganizing around to
support in the last
few months.
So expect it to roll out to you,
and you'll start to get
in touch with some of our
fantastic dev rel team, but
also a new team that's coming
together to be more of a
partner manager.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Henry
Sztul with Shelby.tv.
You guys have done a great job
with making accessing videos
on Android more accessible.
It think it was a new
API initiative this
past year or so.
Do you see that moving to iOS
in the near future, as well?
Or is that mainly an
Android-only direction?
ANDY BERKHEIMER: We're
actually looking.
We'd love to bring that
to iOS as well.
We're looking into ways we can
do that that kind of meet our
needs in terms of being
able to provide
updates in a timely way.
We were able to find a
solution on Android.
We haven't been able to find
a solution on iOS yet.
That's something that's
definitely top of our mind and
something that we're
looking into.
But we don't have any sort of
specific news to share there.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's
[? Layton. ?]
Just a simple question
for you guys.
Are you considering any video
post-processing stuff like
reduce the noise or bringing
brighter to the video content?
Thanks.
ANDY BERKHEIMER:
In short, yes.
Actually, one of our talks
this week is around video
stabilization and around some of
the post-processing that we
make available there.
If you actually look into our
upload tools, I think we've
recently started to expose some
of the controls to enable
a few of those post-processing
steps through our Upload API.
And we have a lot of great
engineering teams doing
research into how we can bring
more of those capabilities
into our pipeline and
then expose those
through Upload API.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Now's a great
time for feedback on that,
actually, particularly around
the stabilization talk, but
generally for us too.
ANDY BERKHEIMER: And I
definitely encourage you to go
to the stabilization
talk this week.
And you'll be able to talk to
the developers there and
provide some feedback on what
else you'd like to see.
AUDIENCE: Um, [? Megan. ?]
So the gate G.APIs you
have, you've got v2
and you've got v3.
I'm curious when v2 will be
fully deprecated, just because
v3 isn't completely flushed out,
so we find ourselves sort
of balancing between when
we make a v2 call
and a v3 query call.
And then the other ones that
[INAUDIBLE] came up here has
to do with the Freebase in the
topic IDs, in terms of how
those things are tagged and how
frequently those are updated.
Just an example being we had a
Daft Punk music video that I
had in a integration test,
thinking that the topic IDs
were always going to
stay the same.
And it went from having four
tags that were fairly specific
to accurate to the last time I
ran it, it just had one tag
for electronic music genre.
So I'm just trying to figure
out what the process is on
keeping those updated
and how much we can
rely on those things.
ANDY BERKHEIMER: Remind
me what your first
question was, again?
AUDIENCE: v2 versus v3.
ANDY BERKHEIMER: Yes.
So v2 versus v3.
We're working to bring v3 up to
complete parity as quickly
as possible.
And we're not going
to deprecate v2
until that's the case.
And so that's the short
answer there.
And as we get v3 to that point,
we'll announce it and
roll it out and expect some
communication there in the
next couple of months.
On the Topics API, I don't
actually know directly myself
what the update process is, what
guarantees we make there.
We actually have Shirley and a
couple of engineers from the
Topics team who will be giving
a talk later this week.
And it'd be great to ask
them that question.
They can go into a lot more
detail there than I can.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Yeah.
And I'll add one
point on that.
Right now we kind of give you
one central topic around a
video through the API.
So one of the things
we want to do is--
we don't have the specific
date on this.
Go to that session and provide
them feedback, but expand the
number of topics.
The issue is that centrality can
shift over time for many
of these things.
And one becomes a meme, and
something else happens.
We get more metadata.
So what we want to do is give
developers, effectively, a
broader spectrum of the topics
associated with video, such
that you can rank and decide
what's important for you.
And you have more stability.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I noticed
it's [INAUDIBLE].
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: How much of focus is
our support for TV devices?
And I ask in particular
because this week, you
launched pay-for channels, but
none of those videos actually
work on my Google TV devices.
ANDY BERKHEIMER: Ah.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: And you're
talking specifically about
consumption, not developers
building for a TV.
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: Both.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Both.
OK.
ANDY BERKHEIMER: So actually,
we're rolling that out.
That will be coming
on TV devices.
That's actually--
it's available on some of our
devices today that'll be
coming out to Google TV
devices very soon.
And when it comes out to Google
TV, it will also be
baked into the Android Player
API, which works on
Google TV as well.
So that's when you've got
about eight different
platforms out there, getting
them all launched on the same
day is pretty tricky.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: And just to
add some color to that.
As we think about distribution
of YouTube app on a variety of
TVs, one thing we've not focused
on is creating a
specific SDK for TV developers
outside of the
Google TV app space.
We're trying to focus more on
getting our app commonly used
with access to all content
available on all
platforms right now.
Many of those platforms, as you
probably know, just aren't
sophisticated to
support a great
developer ecosystem today.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm John
from OpenSlate.
Little detailed question, but
it causes a lot of pain for
us, and we're very, very
concerned about it is
migration from user
IDs to titles.
We've heard that user IDs
are going to go away.
Titles are the way to
go in the future.
We've already seen evidence that
folks are changing titles
to be pretty much like titles
of web pages, so they don't
provide a lot of information and
certainly not a business
link back to the owner
of the channel.
Of course, we have the unique ID
on the other side, but the
user ID has been the key really
for quite a long time.
And the biggest problem that we
see here is the fact that
over on the [? AdEx ?]
side, in the RGB callout, if you
want to target against a
specific channel,
the placements
are still the unique--
still the user IDs.
Is there anything we
can talk about now?
Or is that too detailed
for this conversation?
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: We should
have probably a separate
discussion and go through
some of the use cases.
Like obviously, some of the
things we're doing have to do
with unifying our account
structure across Google+,
YouTube generally, across
all of Google.
And that's going to open up
new opportunities, right?
But we're also going to start
to move from users to
multi-channels and different
types of relationships, which
might complicate
things further.
And so maybe for the sake of
this room, we can just talk
for a little bit right after.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Is it for certain that
user ID will--
it's 100% certain that's
going away?
ANDY BERKHEIMER: Well,
effectively, the notion of a
one-to-one mapping between
user IDs and
channels is going away.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Right.
Yeah.
In terms of the right thing to
target on, we should have a
deeper discussion.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: I'm Danilo from
DADC load entertainment.
I actually know Jarek and
Jussi from Everyplay.
Very interested to see the whole
combination because I
work in a company that
makes games--
[INAUDIBLE]
game development and
game consoles.
And we also do video
app development.
So I'm very interested to see
when this whole thing would be
coming to Android and what kind
of multiplayer and live
streaming multiplayer support
could be coming from Google
and YouTube as APIs, just
because the new Google Play
Game Services--
you're just trying to put all
of those things in just like
one awesome app that you will be
playing a game and will be
streaming it live.
And at the same time, your
friends will be able to be
spectating that experience.
But I think we will need to
work with mood [INAUDIBLE]
inside of YouTube and Google
to make that work.
So we just would like to see
and hear from you guys what
would be your support for live
streaming gaming and
multiplayer support
from YouTube.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: I think
one of the--
there's two pieces.
One is our Live APIs are
obviously available now.
And we expect to see a lot of
people using them to actually
make that live streaming case
for many games effectively
possible today.
Starting today, I should say,
with a few exceptions who
started a little bit earlier.
And so in terms of how that
integrates with the broader
Google Play SDK and what's there
available for a game and
whether that's turn key and how
much that's tied to that
specific graph and that type of
thing, you do have to work
with multiple people.
But you do have a group,
particularly--
can the dev rels actually
stand up?--
who are doing a lot of stuff
here and kind of spanning a
lot of different areas too.
So it might be really
interesting to talk deeper
session what you're trying
to achieve and see if the
existing APIs do it.
Or at least there's a good
recipe book for how to use the
multiple APIs that are available
and make it happen.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Mike from
Collective Digital Studios.
One of the big things a lot of
our users want is the full
list of their subscribers.
And we've had--
I noticed you can get it through
channel list, but
there's been issues with it.
And I think it's capped at 1,000
is the last I heard.
Is there plans to be able
to get back your
full subscriber list?
SHIVA RAJARAMAN:
Yeah, there is.
Do you know where
it is, Jarek?
I caught you on the spot.
Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
So we're doing two things.
One is a lot of those enterprise
use cases you have
through the Analytics API
can page through a whole
subscriber list.
So I need to double check
and make sure
there's no cap on that.
But our principle is
not to cap it.
So if you do actually want to
use that, it makes sense.
Some of the issues we might have
are particularly around
what's a minimum cluster size
you can have for your
subscribers before you
can do audience
analytics on that cluster.
And that's more of a privacy
protection issue.
But in terms of getting the
public subscriber list, we
know it's been frustrating.
If you're looking at what some
folks are doing, they're
crawling and/or getting it
partially through the API.
The goal is to release
the full list.
But you can actually follow up
with me, and I'll get you the
right answer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name's [? Sunat ?] from
France 24 news TV channel.
We've been trying to integrate
the live broadcasting to our
process, our workflow.
We are very concerned about
the fact that we have to
create an event each time we
have to broadcast something.
And when we want to stream,
our channel never changes.
The configuration we are
broadcasting to changes every
time we create an event.
Do you plan to create stable
sources we can broadcast--
how would I say--
continuously?
ANDY BERKHEIMER: You
want a single
event ID that you reuse?
Is that basically your--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We could broadcast
continuously to the same server.
And then we could create
events, based on
the same only source.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: [INAUDIBLE]
but actually we are enabling
it to go actually longer.
And that you don't need
to change the event.
You can only have one event.
And this event will actually
go over to that four hours.
And so you don't need to change
the event from now on.
So we actually will
enable it soon.
And we are working on it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name is Gabriel from
[INAUDIBLE].com.
When can we expect a deeper
integration between the
Google+ API and the
YouTube API?
We have been trying to play
with the login content for
subscriber-based Google+
circles.
But in some ways, you need the
user to be able to do that
program [INAUDIBLE].
But we didn't find a way, even
listing that, asking that in
the YouTube API, the answer was
there is something that we
are working on.
But we don't have any
dates yet for it.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: I think, is the
question about whether--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean--
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Get the
same-- like through the
YouTube API, get the
subscriber--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like
integration.
You have features that you can
use both YouTube and Google+.
But still you cannot use
them through the API.
I mean, are you doing releases
based on that or the focus is
on the Analytics API?
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: So, one, you
should just talk about how
we're approaching API-developed
based
development.
And in terms of the specific
Google+ versus YouTube--
we're in the process of getting
people to connect
these accounts so that we
have single graphs.
And until that happens and keeps
getting progress, it's
hard to expose it all
through one source.
But our goal right now
is to have channels
backed by Plus pages.
There's a lot of other
discussions happening on that
as well so that these start
to look more similar.
And these objects have mappings
that we can actually
then start to expose.
But in the meantime, building on
APIs, absolutely, but this
is the guy.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I'm Mark
from Pixability.
I'm wondering are you planning
on having an
AdWords for Video API?
Or is there any movement towards
that or any sort of
kind of developer tools around
those creating campaigns, on a
thing like that?
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Yeah,
there is some
progress on that front.
We're not the experts on
that actually, though.
But I can follow up with you.
AUDIENCE: Great.
AUDIENCE: I think,
a quick question.
Have you guys considered or is
there a way for you to return
the cost in v3 for individual
queries, so we could do a
little better housekeeping on
our end or accounting, I
guess, properly, on our end
to know how we're doing?
Or maybe that's reflected in
us not having a perfect
understanding of what
things cost.
ANDY BERKHEIMER: This is cost
as it relates to quota
enforcement?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ANDY BERKHEIMER: I think
that's a pretty
good feature request.
I don't know if--
It's definitely a feature
request we've
looked at in the past.
I'm looking at Jarek to
see if we've done
anything about that now.
But--
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: No.
ANDY BERKHEIMER: What?
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: It's just--
JAREK: [INAUDIBLE].
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: But
no specific--
OK.
It's a good feature request.
ANDY BERKHEIMER: We have some
practices, but it's not
structured data at the moment.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: You want
a per query type cost,
effectively.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Noah
from FanBridge.
As you guys build up this crop
of people who aren't
necessarily content partners but
are serving those people,
certain parts of the API fork
to let only data access to
content partners.
Are you guys thinking about
merging those together, so
someone who isn't a content
partner but has content
partner clients can still
access that same data?
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: And this is for
the cases where you're not
trying to get your
own data, right?
You're just trying to use
YouTube as a data source
across all the content?
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: So if an MCN is a
client, we can show them their
earnings data and things like
that that are only available
through content owner APIs.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Oh, without
having access to their auth?
AUDIENCE: With their auth?
But we're not the
content owner.
We're not an MCN.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Yeah,
so we do have--
I don't know if Jarek, you can
talk about that, but it's
effectively like "acting
on behalf of," right?
So that's something we're
working on right now.
AUDIENCE: As it relates to v3
calls, part of the best
practices includes
using e-tags.
And I could see why you'd
want us to do that.
But there doesn't seem
to be any benefit
on the actual quota.
So I can have a bunch of things,
query e-tags, get a
bunch of 304s back.
But it still seems to eat into
my quota the same as if I
didn't even use an e-tag.
Is there going to be
a change in that?
Or what's the advantage of me
using an e-tag, then, if it
doesn't really help my quota,
I guess is the point I'm
trying to--
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: Specifying a
part and getting less quota
accordingly?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ANDY BERKHEIMER: Yeah, I mean
the biggest advantage right
now is in the data transfer
and being able to get the
response faster.
In many cases, being able to
generate a 304 still requires
just as much back end work.
And so yeah, I think
that's kind of
reflected through the cost.
SHIVA RAJARAMAN: We're going
to have to cut it off now?
OK.
So thanks, everyone.
We'll definitely follow up
with the quota stuff.
And people had some specific
questions we couldn't answer,
feel free to shoot me a note,
and we'll follow up.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]